morning all these lads are the better
part of our growing Confederacy Here I
am sonography I'm sure yet easily i'm
alex ferguson episode I'm Anthony Newman
from Naughty Dog the creators of the
last of us I'm 249 from shinola the
creative device take i'm cholena million
from squad and creator and develop in
the space program my name is Joseph Aris
from starbreeze studios hi I'm Dennis
Lee from Namco Bandai Games America on
behalf of level five and studio G with
creators of knee no kuni wrath of the
white witch hi I'm Rex for Media
Molecule graces of tear away we've been
nominated for a bunch of game developers
choice awards we're nominated for a 2014
game developers choice award watch live
on gamespot on march to 19th to see if
device 6 wins watch it live on gamespot
on March 19 to see if me no kuni wins
and remember no volvere c4 as your
favorite game for the audience award
your mobile KSP is your favorite game
free audience in there but please go
vote for brothers a tale of two soft go
vote Bernie no kuni wrath of the white
witch as your favorite game for the
audience award go vote for the last of
us as your favorite game for the
audience award before voting closes on
march first before voting closes on
march the first so go Beaufort airway is
your favorite game with the audience
award before voting closes on marks the
first thanks very much
you